la france est en guerre
les actes commis vendredi soir à paris
et près du stade de france sont des
actes de guerre le congrès normalement
la réuni quand on veut réviser la
constitution etc
c'est une réponse politique à cette nuit
d'horreur
[Musique]
on est le lundi 16 novembre donc on se
réveille après ce week end horreur ce
sont les attentats les plus meurtriers
de l'histoire de france
les hommes tirent à l'armé lourde sur
les passants des scènes de guerre en
plein coeur de la capitale pour la
première fois en france il s'agit d'être
à kamikaze est effectivement dès lundi
le premier acte politique de la semaine
c'est de réunir les députés les
sénateurs en congrès il ya une ambiance
qui est évidemment très grave très
lourde et très digne il ya un très long
couloir à parcourir je crois que c'est
une trentaine de secondes ce qui est
énorme en fait quand on voit l'homme
d'état seul marché il n'y a aucun bruit
c'est vraiment les représentants de la
nation qui sont tous là et les partis
politiques n'existent plus entre
guillemets c'est la france par ses
représentants qui est réunie au congrès
de versailles
vous êtes les représentants des peuples
libres qui est invincible
quand il est uni et rassemblé c'est
notre bien le plus précieux
mais nous devons éviter surenchère et
dérives
nous devons pouvoir déchoir de sa
nationalité française
un individu condamné pour une atteinte
aux intérêts fondamentaux de la nation
ou un acte terroriste
même s'il est né français il y avait une
volonté d'une réponse politique très
ferme
effectivement la déchéance de
nationalité est présenté comme une
mesure symbolique et très forte contre
le terrorisme mais beaucoup à gauche ne
vont absolument pas se retrouver dans
cette mesure est la gauche va se diviser
entièrement est vraiment sur cette
question de la déchéance de nationalité
le terrorisme ne détruira pas la
république car c'est la république qui
le détruira vive la république et vive
la france
[Applaudissements]
il y avait une marseillaise spontanée
après les attentats de charlie hebdo et
l'hyper cacher s'est passé la même chose
au congrès à versailles
le congrès de versailles c'est le moment
où lcp je pense se dit qu'elle vit un
moment qui sera écrit dans les livres
d'histoire
[Musique]